to kick-off the 2019 Karen's Cup we're
here today at the community day with
Scouts BSA which as of two days ago are
now allowing girls to join the scouting
program so we have our very first
all-girls scouting merit badge for chess
[Music]
a group of girls who came out to get
their Scouts merit badge and these are
among the first girls ever to get this
badge it was really exciting I gave a
little presentation about some of the
top tactics from women players in the
world which I thought was a really fun
kickoff for the day and for the Karen's
Cup
so now boys and girls are both in the
program the kickoff was February first
so we saw that this is one of the first
merit badge skill centers available for
girls right after the kickoff so we have
two girls from our troop very excited
and I see there's lots of other girls
from the area that are joining so it's
really exciting to see such interest in
the area another thing that really
excited me was to see the girls helping
each other because that's a lot about
what getting the badge is not just about
becoming a good chess player it's also
about community and making sure that
other people can get the benefits of
chess
[Music]
having the top female players in the
world here in st. Louis is really a
great opportunity for st. Louis area
girls who have joined the scouting
program to be able to to see their idols
and meet some of these amazing chess
players and to learn what it's like to
be a professional female chess player
[Music]